just a reminder that the squad is
garbage just there it's filled with
terrible people so
over the past 48 hours there was an
attempt by the democrats to
push republicans to basically
push for spending bills by including in
spending bills things like funding for
iron dome which is the israeli defense
system and the squad voted it down like
members of the squad who were in favor
of increasing the spending republicans
voted against it because they didn't
want to increase the spending period
democrats were in favor of increasing
the spending they just didn't like
israel at least members of the squad
so rashida talib is just the
d hamas in the like she's she's just a
terrorist representative apparently in
the american congress because that's all
she does just stand for hamas so she
went out there and she said she was very
upset that now the democrats brought up
correctly a separate funding bill for
one billion dollars for iron dome which
is a purely defensive technology and
rashida talib said she didn't want any
funding for war crimes
i will not support an effort to enable
and support war crimes human rights
abuses and violence we cannot be talking
only about israelis need for safety at a
time when palestinians are living under
a violent apartheid system and are dying
from what human rights watch has said
are war crimes
okay speaker of the house nancy pelosi
was like um the hell are you talking
about iron dome is a purely defensive
system designed to safeguard all
civilians living in israel the system
was co-developed by the united states
and israel and has saved thousands of
lives so whatever subsidy we were paying
to israel were getting back in terms of
the technology
um and pretty much everybody voted for
it right everybody
the final vote on this thing had i think
nine people who did not vote for it
uh ted deutsch the representative from
palm beach he uh he came out he's a
democrat and finally i'm refuted to
leave as the anti-semite he's only two
years late on this
i cannot allow one of my colleagues to
stand on the floor of the house of
representatives
and label the jewish democratic state of
israel in apartheid state i reject it
let's be clear it's consistent with
those who advocate
for the dismantling of the one jewish
state in the world
and when there is no place on the map
for one jewish state
that's anti-semitism yes it most
certainly is and the anti-semites
include representatives rashid talib
ilhan omar no shock there i mean they're
just openly allied at this point with
hamas ayanna presley the ringo star of
the squad cory bush the blm
congresswoman from missouri that's also
not a shock because the blm organization
is openly anti-semitic andre carson
marie newman jesus garcia and raul
grivalva
and one republican representative thomas
massey who voted against because he
votes against pretty much every funding
bill and that is that is why massey
voted against it now because he's
anti-israel just because he doesn't like
pretty much any funding
aoc
is the one we should focus on here so
originally the vote came around and aoc
voted against funding iron dome
then aoc backed off a bit because as
always she is just cosplaying the
revolution that is all she wants to be
seen as radical but then when it comes
right down to it she just wants power
and money that's all she wants aoc she
wants to run for senate in new york
you ain't getting far running for the
senate in new york being overtly
anti-semitic the way that hannah
maharashtra to libar alejandra can get
away with it because she's from a
district in minnesota
that is extraordinarily
far left and radical against israel
and the same is true for rashida talib
that is not true for it may be true in
her district it is certainly not true
statewide so whatever hope she has for
statewide office rests on her abstaining
so she actually abstained from this
but you know she she did have to cry
some crocodile tears so no tears for the
people
who are attempting to cross the border
down in in del rio texas no cheers about
that but she broke out the the sobbing
again after switching her votes she knew
where the cameras were because she
always knows where the cameras are i
mean she's like a moth to a flame when
it comes to cameras aoc made her way
down while somebody else was speaking
and then
pretty overtly started
dabbing at her eyes because she was so
sad that she had abstained from this
from this particular bill so terrible
that israel has defensive technology to
prevent its citizens from being
slaughtered on mass by a terrorist group
firing rockets indiscriminately into
civilian areas
destiny by mr lawson
you can see her
approach
she walks up to a fellow congress person
and she's she's so sad she's upset
and she removes her glasses she knows
exactly where the camera is this whole
time right she removes her glasses and
she starts dabbing at her eyes ah
oh the sadness oh
the pain
ah
she is just terrible
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feed